july 2021 was the hottest month in
modern history and few places were
hotter than the middle east and north
africa where sea and land temperatures
neared or hit new records here in the
gulf we're used to scorching heat with
temperatures that regularly top 45
degrees celsius 113 degrees fahrenheit
scientists like george zitis say this
heat will only get more extreme we have
very strong amounts of solar radiation
very low cloud cover and precipitation
this is causing the extreme
environmental conditions that we see in
the region
and we expect this to become worse in
the future data studied by zitis and his
team indicate that business as usual in
greenhouse gas emissions will soon cause
unprecedented heat waves in the
mediterranean a heat and a decline in
precipitation could drive more intense
droughts like the ones that created the
conditions for wildfires in places like
greece turkey and algeria this summer in
the gulf heat waves could top 56 degrees
celsius and last for weeks
actually we're expecting to reach the
limits of survivability in parts of the
region so human discomfort will be
really high we expect to have direct
impacts for example heat strokes heat
tolerant animals could be affected
coastal cities in the persian gulf like
dubai and daha have already felt
conditions close to these limits humans
regulate their body temperature by
sweating but at high enough levels of
heat and humidity a so-called wet bulb
temperature sweat won't evaporate fast
enough for humans to keep body heat in
check for more than a few hours
air conditioning is mostly ubiquitous in
the gulf but temperature extremes pose a
new challenge when the dry bulb and wet
build temperature increases the humidity
goes up and these big cooling towers
which are responsible for giving us the
cold air inside would not be enough to
give you a comfortable temperature
inside the house flashy plans for
futuristic sustainable cities like neom
and saudi arabia may someday allow for
more efficient living in the gulf
but for now inefficient air conditioning
and energy subsidies are two of the
reasons these countries are among the
world's worst polluters we did some
analysis and we found that one degree
increase in the temperature
outdoor
will increase by 10 percent the air
conditioning energy use in riyadh but
there is limited initiative at least the
existing what we call the old build
retrofit and actually this is not a
problem for the gulf that's throughout
the world but there's a potential upside
jobs we estimate about a quarter of a
million per year over 10 years in saudi
arabia we mitigate climate change we
reduce the amounts of greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere
the temperature will still increase but
in a much slower pace and this will
provide us the window that we need to
adapt in doha simone foxman bloomberg
news